i was watching rollo's video about all
the lost boys the other day you recently
talked about that right
and
when you see the proliferation of this
this story of lost boys or
or people just getting swept up in
everything whether it's blue pill this
or or communism or socialism or just
random ideologies getting swept up in it
and they're just searching for meaning
in different places
um one of the things that you guys
always mention is that you know
the red pill is a tool and do what you
want with it well the thing is like
that's a lot of responsibility and a lot
of people might not be ready for that a
lot of people they just want the
prescription they just want like tell me
what to do and so they're gonna look for
something that tells them what to do and
so they're just going to
you know get picked up by whatever
happens to pick them up and so wouldn't
it be a good idea to have
some type of prescription for people who
are afraid to choose for themselves
essentially
right
i understand i get what you're saying in
fact as a matter of fact um that's
really been the story of humankind for a
very long time at least as far as i'm
concerned um
it's tell me what to do where do i go
um yeah what what is uh what is my in
religion
ruler right yeah it's cheap in search of
a shepherd uh you want to know why there
is lost boys right now we keep bringing
this back up and this is not a new story
by the way i think if you saw my show
yesterday you understand what i'm saying
um
but i i used to think by the way and i
had i had to change my mind about this
too um when i was talking with dr piper
and i and mentioned him in the book uh
there was a point where um dr everett
piper was saying well you know everybody
believes in something there's no such
thing as a real atheist they all have to
have some sort of belief set even if
that belief is in
whatever and that i i really resisted
that for a long time i'm like you know
what the hell is this guy talking about
you just because you just because you're
religious doesn't mean everybody else is
religious and but there's still that
human need for hope there's still that
human need for magical thinking to some
degree
so if we would not have like marvel
superheroes if we didn't have a capacity
from for magical thinking we wouldn't
have star wars we wouldn't have all of
these great you know in flights of fancy
and magical you know uh stories if we
didn't have some sort of capacity for
imagination and i tried to make this uh
maybe
maybe i should have spent a little more
time on this but i i made the case and i
i remember the quote i think it was
albert einstein who says you know what's
more important imagination or knowledge
and the answer is always well
imagination because you've got to think
about like no there's a balance they're
both equally important i think but you
can't have one without the other you
don't get to knowledge without
imagination you don't have you can't
like further imagination without
knowledge
and so when i was discussing that i'm
like there's a point where like the our
men's
a human being's uh capacity for magical
thought or magical thinking is actually
a feature of our brains rather than a
bug it can be a bug it can be horrible
but it's also the that side of our our
nature that that that module of our
brain wherever it is that has the
ability to believe that something could
be better or weak as men and in this
case can exercise our will
idealistically on the world that has to
come from somewhere and it doesn't come
from just knowledge it comes from the
belief that maybe something what's
what's beyond the river let's put let's
build a bridge how do we do that let's
figure it out let's imagine a bridge and
put it across the river so that same
capacity for imaginative thought that
inspiration whatever it is we can call
it idealism that is a very
fantastic one of the best benefits of
being a human being is to have to be
able to do that that capacity for
magical thought but it's also
something that can be easily exploited
and it's also responsible for some of
the worst atrocities in human history so
if we believe that you know we should uh
the you know the jewish holocaust right
that's that's the way that things should
be should our imagination says that this
is what we should do or religious wars
or whatever it is or bombing you're
believing that you're going to go to
paradise if you strap a bomb to yourself
magical thinking atrocity as a result
but it's the same it's the same
mechanism that leads to
to one behavior or the other behavior
and so when i was talking to dr verber
and he was saying you know everybody
believes in something i'm like you know
what maybe he's right because i see
especially in woke culture right now
that's basically a religion when you
look at the emotionalism and i make the
case in the back in the end of the book
here that emotionalism is going to end
up being sort of this world religion
it's it's not going to be islam or
christianity or whatever it'll be this
sort of you know whirlwind or world you
know
whirlpool of of beliefs that are based
on like love and that's intolerance and
that's and where if you if you don't if
you're against them then you're a hater
kind of thing
and i didn't really this didn't wasn't
really brought home to me until i was
actually up in lake tahoe recently and i
saw this like placard card and i'm sure
you've seen them because it's like a
black background and it has this rainbow
uh lettering and it says in this house
we believe in black lives matter science
is real uh you know uh love love wins
and all of these sort of like lingo and
this jargon and stuff and i thought
about this from a minute and i go that's
a statement of belief
so like when you go to church for the
first time and you're visiting the
church they give you that little
brochure and it says
in this church we believe the bible is
the unerring word of god blah blah blah
and it goes through these statements of
belief i looked at that placard and i go
that is exactly the same statement that
you would get if you went to a church
in this house we believe
xxx right and so there is a need i think
that is a result of that part of that
module in our brain to have something
where we believe in hope or we believe
whatever it is because at somewhere
along the line we had to believe that we
can live a better life we had to believe
that we can get out of a hopeless
situation so when i'm dealing with like
black pill dumers or whatever it's like
i'm not necessarily struggling against
their sort of you know innate autism or
whatever it's also this lack of belief
and so i have to kind of keep that in
mind when i'm dealing with these guys
right now so i i would agree with you
but i think that it's i think it can be
broken down into sort of like nuts and
bolts a little bit more than just like
well we all need to believe in this one
religion and we'll we'll save the west
or from degeneracy
yeah yeah all right
thanks for posing the question man sorry
that's probably more than you needed but
i thought that was interesting that was
awesome thank you
you